creating the label that you are now this
way because is the problem not the thing
so for everybody who's listening to this
if you have something bad happen you can
think I will subscribe to the traumatic
experience that my counselor has told me
that I have gone through and they've
labeled this thing and then I get to
have I just get to keep this problem
with me forever whenever I go into new
relationship say I was traumatized
earlier like I have a hard time trusting
people because of this reason that I'm
making up right now okay cool or
something happened okay moving on that's
the problem is the label that people
describe to whatever circumstance